so we're here for the gravel and Gold
Tour I want to know the significance
behind that album title if you could
tell me oh sure man well the the lead
song off that album is called gold and
it mentions gravel and gold and just the
you know how they both exist daily right
you have gravel in your life things that
annoy you and they have Great Moments
your life and uh really the idea behind
that song the album some ways is just
perspective you know like taking the
stuff that you think is gravel and
turning into gold and for me it's kind
of natural you know I was living in
Colorado during the pandemic and
some of the folks my family wanted to
come back to Nashville so we came back
to Nashville and Nashville that point I
think I was just sick of it you know
I've been there for 30 years and getting
a lot of tourists and it's getting kind
of crowded and it was kind of gravel for
me at that point but I realized when I
got back that it's just it's still such
a great City there's a lot of a lot of
gold left in that City so uh it's kind
of the idea behind that song and really
like kind of a motto I guess in my life
right now about just trying to find the
positive and everything yeah so so
talking of gravel and gold being the
highs and lows of your life yeah
um what percentage would you say your
life right now is gravel versus gold oh
man it's all it's all gold right now
it's just so great I got you know three
great kids um one the one of them's here
with me tonight she'll probably get them
to sing a little bit with me um and you
know just get this tour you know Jordan
Davis will be not here on the road with
us Molly tuttle's opening the show
tonight great Bluegrass singer and just
you know be able to do this for as many
years as I have a great band a great
crew and um but still things are new
like this is my first time playing this
venue in Toronto after all these years
we're still doing things that are
they're new and so that's what keeps us
exciting so it's just it's a lot a lot
of gold right now yeah yeah yeah okay so
true or false you scrapped this album
twice I did and rewrote it because it
wasn't good enough or well yeah so the
first time we're back in the studio yeah
I've been in Colorado and we came back
to Nashville and I got in the studio and
everyone was still wearing masks and
still doing the testing it's just kind
of weird vibe it's hard to be in the
studio when you when you're doing all
that you know it's like you're it just
kind of it's you're trying to
communicate to somebody who's playing
guitar and the drummer's doing this you
can't really communicate when you got
all this stuff on your face so I just
felt like it's missing some little piece
in there on that session within a second
time and it was uh it was just like it
was close but it was just wasn't right
there it's hard to know when you're
actually working on the perfect and the
record's just right you know and that
third time was like wow we definitely
this is it we're making the album it
feels good and and so just just a matter
of getting it right and also trying to
write a few more songs uh to have mixed
away of all the songs locked in who's
like your main Sound Board in your life
like who do you bounce things off of is
it your families industry friends yeah
you know always bounce things with my
wife she's she's a good get a good ear
Fortune we've known each other since
eighth grade so she she can tell me
straight whether something's if
something's good or not and uh so you're
not making you say that right here
the guy's my band uh just friends that I
I write songs with and but uh just hard
to always get it just you know who to
listen to who not to listen to who
sometimes you to ignore people sometimes
you gotta like just go with what you
believe and other times it's really
helpful to listen to folks and really
use their opinions uh because certainly
people the record label I trust and
believe in and they have some good
knowledge so it's I really take my job
as like taking all the information then
make a decision and I like to listen to
many people as possible so you're good
at taking criticism you know yes you're
like okay I don't got criticism I'm
saying like do you like to be someone to
be brutally honest with you like to
sugarcoat a little bit no sensitive you
know sometimes one of my shows I mean
I'd rather them tell me like what they
thought I'd draw or who do better than
just saying okay oh it was a good show
like that doesn't really help me when
you say it's just a good show what does
that even mean I want to hear like
either super passionate about something
either either direction you know okay
yeah so 20 years in the industry 10
Studio albums what advice would you give
a young Dierks Bentley government coming
into this industry uh you know young me
young anybody it's just it's all about
passion for you know it's all about
Obsession for it it doesn't matter how
good of a singer you are or how what
kind of work ethic you have unless
you're like really you love this you
know everybody you do your job everyone
does they do hopefully find something to
really they love doing and it doesn't
feel like work because they're just like
man I love doing this I would do it for
free it's just what I you know and
that's what country music was for me and
I always say I'm not the most talented
guy but there you'd never find anybody
that loves it country music more than I
do I do or is more obsessive really you
know from day one I've just always I've
been obsessed about it you know from the
history of it to making it certainly
being on the road now playing it live I
just I love all aspects of everything I
get to do yeah so before all this you
know we we all have to make a living
somehow yeah what was the the worst job
you ever had before the fame oh man and
the fortune
pretty bizarre kind of gross jobs I I
worked at a helped build and then worked
at a driving range that was built on top
of a dump so when it rained you know
pieces the little grass that existed but
kind of washed away see the old old dirt
pile cleaning golf balls there later on
and then I also worked at a marina a
couple Summers me too you did yeah my
job was these houseboats to come back
and I would pump all those pumps up
right yeah yeah 250 gallon holding tank
on there had this old machine you hook
it up to it and there's just four levers
and they weren't labeled and she'd be
like I think it's these two and if
you're wrong it'd take the lake water
and shoot it back in and it was I had
some near disasters there for sure yes
yeah you know what I'm talking about
I've been a part of that yeah and it's
not good yeah those detaches from the
septic tank and it's shooting straight
up in the sky and you're just running
trying to like make it off the dock into
the water before it all comes down yeah
no that's not I ran into some problems
and wasn't able to change after they're
like nope just you know finish the day
yeah right there I guess just finishing
it yeah we wore white collared shirts
I'm not sure why they chose white I mean
yeah
black uh so you're on tour now how is
touring changed over 20 years 20 years
ago touring is not oh for me a lot of
things stay the same you know a lot of
the same guys in my van my crew I'm
still riding on the same bus I had back
2003 or 2003 yeah yeah three uh same bus
you know I hold on to things that like
the song says so uh I love the people I
work with I you know I want to always be
growing this thing together so a lot of
it hasn't changed in that way um of
course for us things got a little bigger
and a production wise is a little more
uh able to do a little bit more in that
regard but it's still the same idea of
like trying to take the crowd on them
you know trying to build a roller
coaster ride with the set list
and have supporting uh production take
the crowd on a ride every night you know
we hit them up and come out of the gate
Up Tempo and fun and then take my little
ride then bring it down somewhere with a
heavier song and then you know take it
on take them on a ride the way out and
yeah so a lot of things really haven't
changed I got some you know sometimes my
kids come out on the road so that's
changed a little bit but they've gotten
the point now they're all pretty
self-sufficient so um it's kind of like
going right back to the beginning yeah
that's cool yeah um okay I need to ask
you about Doug douglasson you know yeah
you're a good friend you know Hot
Country Nights yeah just release a new
song yeah
um harassment yes uh kind of a playlist
it's pretty cool I like it he linked up
with Lainey Wilson yeah you know darling
darling McFarland yeah young darling um
what was your reaction when you heard
that song for the first time yeah well I
so
you know Laney actually approached me at
a CMA Awards in Nashville with that idea
for her song I kind of laughed about it
but she kept hit me up about it so
eventually we wrote it the two of us
wrote that with two other friends and uh
man she Darla McFarland and Lenny Wilson
they just love the nice they love Hot
Country Nights so she really is the
reason why we got back in there and and
got back in the studio cut that song
another song called Midnight audio which
we'll be doing tonight yep midnight with
a K Rodeo um to the Hot Country Nights
uh with the K and uh it's it's just fun
I mean it's just they're a great band
they uh they go on after us they it's
kind of a weird thing to talk about us
They who are they yeah um but man people
love that 90s country and uh that song
harassment's really funny and uh she's
just really it's really fun to get a
chance to sing with her yeah uh her
being Darla and Laney yeah both both
yeah and uh yeah it was super fun and uh
it's it's a great part of our show I
think and some people look you know I
always say 25 of the crowd is really
excited to see the Hawkers nights 25 are
slightly confused but still happy we
were there 25 I have no idea what's
going on and the last 25 are just angry
angry that we're there bring Dirk's back
who are these guys they have no idea so
it's kind of fun does Doug uh have a
line of crop tops coming out or what's
going on you know Doug he started off
this kind of sexy like ladies man he's
turned into more like an ed Bundy type
no I think thanks thanks to my tour he's
going to go through a uh start working
out yeah and get back and she can get
back to his former His Glory Days right
now he's gonna he's not looking so good
A little bit of that beer belly yeah he
wears that crop top shirt and I've been
seeing his picture on some of the badges
oh yeah I know it's not a good look he
has the bananas tucked in yeah it's uh
he's he's kind of falling off a little
bit you know which I didn't think is
possible for him to fall off any more
than he already had but he's not looking
so good a little rough around the edges
okay yeah so for you being in the
industry for 20 years what kind of
advice would you give to somebody like
Lainey Wilson who's coming up and what
what's a mistake that some artists made
coming into this to this business yeah I
mean I look those are like lady I mean I
I draw just as much to them then as they
might draw from me you know like a Molly
Tuttle who's had her today Jordan Davis
you know I'm always you know checking
how they're doing and seeing what new
ways to interact with the crowd
certainly through social media are they
doing but I just say um you don't miss
any of the Rings of the ladder you know
it's like
I went out open for Kenny Chesney a
couple years and then I went right to
Arenas I played bars my whole life bars
bars bars bars bars home for Kenny and
then I went right to trying to play my
own Arenas and it had like two years out
there I just got my butt kicked I mean
and you know we've been playing places
that hold 20 000 people and only 2 000
were showing up so uh had to go back and
kind of backtrack a little bit to get on
again but uh yeah just enjoy the ride
and uh don't don't miss any of the steps
along the way because really those early
years are so fun you know it's great
playing amphitheaters it's great playing
stadiums I can only imagine but you know
you really look back a lot of good
memories on playing the bars the clubs
and the theaters and and just you know
you're always trying to get get going
somewhere but it's good to enjoy those
moments too so don't miss any steps
don't miss any steps okay so last last
thing for you we just heard that you
were hosting the NHL awards yeah at the
end of the month yeah I know you're a
big hockey fan you play hockey go go ice
holes um what would you give yourself a
rating as a hockey player we gotta hear
it because everyone you know I heard you
have a grinder in the corners right I'm
not like it's like you know like that it
was kind of like my I'm not the guy who
scored the pucks you don't have the big
Slap Shot in the back but I I will out
hustling it's not like my my country
music career okay I will work harder
than you were to get to where I need to
be so
um yeah I guess a grinder is a good good
term for me as a hockey player and uh
that's a hockey term folks yeah and uh
and uh yeah but I love the sport looking
forward to watching the finals you know
Maple Leafs had a good run they got some
core guys and I was excited to see him
get into the second round but uh maybe
next year maybe maybe next year guys
yeah